>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, D.C.
>> John Cole: Welcome to
the Library of Congress.
I'm John Cole.
I'm the Director of the Library
of Congress' Center for the Book.
That's the office that helps promote
books and reading and the Center
of the Book and the Young Reader
Center, which is part of the Center
of the Book welcome you
to the Library of Congress
for our sixth annual Jonah
Solkoff Eskin Memorial Program.
This very special program honors the
memory of Jonah Eskin, son of Barney
and Marsha Eskin, who have paid
for, who have funded this event.
I would like the whole
Eskin family to rise
and let's thank them
for their generosity.
[ Clapping ]
>> John Cole: Well, I should
have said the three members
of the Eskin family, but we are
so appreciative of their help
for this annual talk and program.
The talk has morphed into
a wonderful program today
and this particular program calls
attention to our National Ambassador
for young people's
literature program.
This is program was
initiated in 2008.
Gosh, we're going to reminisce
about this in a few minutes,
but it doesn't seem
that far back to me.
In collaboration with our partner,
the Children's Book Council,
which is located in New York,
which is the trade foundation
for children's book publishers
and they have a foundation
which really administers
the program for all of us.
It's called "Every Child a
Reader" and of course the purpose
of the program itself is to
heighten National awareness
about the importance of books
with young people and children
and the entire literature body
of materials that are available
to our young people today.
The three living Ambassadors,
yes, yes they are.
Jon Scieszka, Katherine
Paterson and Kate DiCamillo.
They are going to join
me in a conversation.
It will be followed, our talk
will be followed by a tribute
to the third National
Ambassador, Walter Dean Myers,
the late Walter Dean Myers
and Walter will be remembered
by his son Christopher Myers,
himself a writer and an illustrator.
We're so pleased, let's
give Christopher,
you'll hear from Christopher soon.
We are so please to have so many
young people joining us today
from areas throughout the
district, Maryland and Virginia
and it's a great pleasure to
have more than 200 students
from the following schools.
When I read your name,
please raise your hands.
From Washington, D.C., Hyde
Addison Elementary School.
Where are you?
There you go.
You have good seats in the center.
Brent Elementary School.
Washington Latin Public
Charter School.
Are you here?
Let's hear from you a little bit.
A little cheer.
There we go.
John Eaton Elementary School.
Alright and the Alice
Beale Middle School.
There we go.
I'd like to hear again from the
Hyde Addison Elementary School.
You weren't in the spirit.
There we go.
Ok. Now, we've accounted
for the D.C. schools.
It looks like the moderator
goofed about the Virginia schools,
but for Maryland we
have Holten Arms School
and Virginia will be
represented the next time
around when we have this.The
National Ambassador program provides
for a two year appointment by
the Librarian of Congress based
on recommendations from a selection
committee representing many segments
of our National book committee.
Excuse me, National book community.
The selection criteria include the
candidate's proven contributions
to young people's literature and
their ability to relate to children.
Our partner, as I mentioned
already, The Center for the Book
and Young Readers Center's partner
is the Children's Book Council
and today I'll also would like to
you meet John Coleman, believe it
or not, the newly appointed
Executive Director
of the Children's Book Council.
John, would you please stand?
Let's give him a hand.
[ Clapping ]
>> John Cole: This other John
will also be part of the ceremony
in January when we make the
announcement at The Library
of Congress of the new
National Ambassador
of the young people's literature,
but that's way in the future.
Today we have a rare opportunity.
We have brought together
the Ambassadors who know
about our program, have
experienced it and we're going
to get their perspective
about their experiences.
How their role has affected their
and, actually, affected their lives.
Now, if they have any
recommendations
for improvement they
can talk to me later.
Ok. Our format is going
to be quite simple.
We will have roughly a
30 minute conversation
with the Ambassadors on the state.
After which, we will
hear from Christopher,
the son of our missing
Ambassador, Walter Dean Myers,
who sadly passed away in July
2014 and whose last book,
"On a Clear Day" was published
posthumously in September 2014.
After Christopher's remarks, he will
join us on the stage and we'll open
up the conversation to our audience
for a 20 minute or so Q & A,
question and answer session.
Because our program is being
videotaped for a later webcast
on The Library of Congress webpage,
we ask that you hold your questions
until that period in the
program when we ask for them
and you will wait for someone
to give you a microphone
so we can record the questions as
well as the answers, of course.
Finally, if you ask a question,
you are giving us your permission
to be part of the webcast
and here is the real final.
If you've not done so already,
please turn off all
the electronic devices.
It's now my pleasure to introduce
you a second time to the Ambassadors
and say a little more about each of
them and I have to be very careful
to do this in chronological order.
Our first Ambassador, as you'll
soon see, there's a great deal
of interaction and a
little bit of jealousy going
on among our Ambassadors and
we'll do our best to bring that up
and I'll try to keep it subdued
so they don't overdue it.
The first is Jon Scieszka,
who served from 2008 to 2009.
Jon wrote his first picture
book in 1989, "The True Story
of the Three Little
Pigs", ok let's hear it.
It has sold over three
million copies
and then translated
into 14 languages.
In addition to many picture
books, his series include,
"The Time Warp Trio",
"Truck Town", "Space Heads"
and a science series,
"Frank Einstein".
Jon's memoir, "Knucklehead:
Tall Tales
and Mostly True Stories Growing Up
Scieszka" was published in 2008.
Jon is the founder of "Guys Read", a
web based literacy program for boys
and its mission is to help
boys become self-motivated,
lifelong readers and Jon himself
is an editor and contributor
to the "Guys Read" book series.
Katherine Paterson.
Our second National Ambassador
served from 20010 through 2011.
Katherine is a two time winner
of The National Book Award
and The Newbery Medal.
Katherine's accolades also include
the Hans Christian Andersen Medal,
The Astrid Lindgren Award and The
Governor's Award for excellence
in the arts, which was given to
her by her home state of Vermont.
And The Library of Congress
has given Katherine,
as part of our bicentennial
celebration in the year 2000,
she received a Living Legend Award
from The Library of Congress.
Katherine's memoir, which I just had
the pleasure of finishing reading,
"Stories of My Life" was
published in 2014 and a film based
on her National book
award winning novel,
"The Great Gilly Hopkins"
has been made
into a film starring Glenn Close,
Kathy Bates and Octavia Spencer.
Give her a hand.
So, she's multi medium.
Our current Ambassador,
Kate DiCamillo.
She began her term after
Walter Dean Myers term.
She began in 2014 and it will
conclude at the end of this year.
Kate has won two Newbery Awards.
In 2001 for, "Because of Winn Dixie"
and in 2014 for "Flora and Ulysses".
She was a finalist for
the National Book Award
for young people's literature
in 2001 for "The Tiger Rising"
and won the Boston Globe Horn
Book Award in 2006 for fiction
for "The Miraculous
Journey of Edward Tulane".
Her platform and each Ambassador
has a choice to pick a theme
or a platform to emphasize
during their two years.
Her platform has been, Stories
Connect Us, which stresses the value
of character and storyline, which
are so appealing in her work.
Two of her books have become films.
In 2005, "Because of Winn Dixie"
was released and the animated story
of "The Tales of Depereaux"
came out in 2008.
Along with her many novels, her
chapter books and picture books,
she plans a yet to be title
novel for readers ten and older
which is due out in
the spring of 2016.
A final welcome for
all three Ambassadors.
[ Clapping ]
>> John Cole: Now, I would
like to start actually
with our current Ambassador, Kate.
Kate this is a nice question,
I think that others may have
some kinds of thoughts about,
but what was it about
the Ambassadorship
that meant the most to you?
You are still in it, I realize.
>> Kate DiCamillo: I was
going to say, am I done?
I have had so many incredible
experiences and I was
so intimidated to do this.
I wouldn't say that I was reluctant,
but I was afraid because you have
to come to The Library of
Congress and you get a medal,
which Jon wears all the time still
and I had to wear a dress and see?
>> Jon Scieszka: I
just happen to have it.
>> Kate DiCamillo: Right?
>> Jon Scieszka: I'll
just put it here.
>> John Cole: There
went my second question.
Let's go back to Kate.
>> Jon Scieszka: Oh, ok.
>> Kate DiCamillo: But it has
been a huge joy to do this
because it has put me in so many
rooms where I have connected
with so many readers and I have
seen the power of reading together.
So, this thing that I went out to
promote that stories connect us,
just instead changed me
profoundly and connected me.
>> John Cole: You feel as though
it's worked for you as the author.
>> Kate DiCamillo: Yes, as
a reader, as a human being.
It has connected me
to so many people
and it has really been
a powerful thing.
So. Jon didn't learn anything.
>> John Cole: Outside of
showing this wonderful medal,
do you want to show the medal now?
>> Jon Scieszka: Well, I
think that would be too much
to show it too often, but I
do wear it down to the deli
to get bagels in the morning.
>> John Cole: What
rewards looking back...
>> Jon Scieszka: Other
than the bagel?
>> John Cole: Other than
the award and the bagel.
>> Jon Scieszka: Actually, very
similar to what Kate experienced.
>> Kate DiCamillo: No, no.
Make up your own answer.
>> Jon Scieszka: No, I was going to
say the same thing the whole time
because I know it will be poetic.
I was just going to say I
loved getting all the stuff.
Starting with the helicopter.
>> John Cole: I promised
him a helicopter
and the best I could do
was a rather small one
that I could fit in my pocket.
>> Jon Scieszka: Yeah, it's
actually the reason I said yes.
>> John Cole: But Jon, do you
hear a whir up above anywhere?
Maybe there's hope for a National...
>> Jon Scieszka: Well, I kinda
love, I remember the phone call
when they asked, like someone just
called out of the blue and said,
do you want this thing,
the National Ambassador,
would you think about it?
And I honestly thought it was a
prank call, was my first response.
My second response was, are you
looking for Katherine Paterson?
I said I don't think you want me.
I'm the stinky cheese and
knucklehead guy, but then I went out
and I had that same experience
where I went out and talked to kids
and I was trying to engage
reluctant readers and just found
out that they weren't
actually reluctant,
they were particular readers.
And it was an education to me to
go just go oh, I actually just got
that all wrong, but I
was glad to have a sash
and my helicopter and my limousine.
>> John Cole: And a cape.
He had a cape.
>> Jon Scieszka: Right
and my fanfare.
Kids wrote some original
music, which I love.
>> John Cole: Let's
come back to that.
Katherine.
>> Jon Scieszka: What do you
mean let's come back to that?
Do you want me to play it?
>> John Cole: No, no, no.
I want to make sure everyone talks
a little bit about the rewards.
>> Jon Scieszka: Who gave
a better answer though?
Do we win points?
>> John Cole: It's
not a point thing.
I'm not keeping score.
>> Kate DiCamillo: Katherine
hasn't spoken yet though.
That will be the best answer.
>> John Cole: Katherine's next?
>> Jon Scieszka: We'll
be quiet then.
>> John Cole: No, no.
Just from your perspective,
were there surprising rewards
that came from this experience?
>> Katherine Paterson: Well,
I think the most fun I had
was when I was a prize.
>> John Cole: Alright.
>> Katherine Paterson: They
offered a prize to the teacher
who gave the best plan
of what she would do
if the National Ambassador would
come to her school and I was won
by a second grade teacher in a
small school in Maine and I live
in Vermont and I thought great,
I don't have to go the ends
of the earth to do this.
What I forgot was that it
was the middle of winter
and I had a friend driving me and
we wouldn't pay an attention to GPS
because we knew better and we were
on the top of Mount Washington
and the GPS kept saying go back, go
back because we were in the middle
of a snow storm on Mount
Washington and there was no internet
or phone reception except the GPS
from my car kept saying
go back, go back.
We couldn't go back.
We couldn't see to go forward.
It was a blizzard and Vermont had
been beautiful the minute we got
through New Hampshire.
I don't want anybody
from New Hampshire
to get their feelings hurt, but as
soon as we got out of New Hampshire
into Maine, it was
beautiful weather again
and it was a beautiful
time at that school.
The teacher was so great explaining
how books had changed her life
as a child, starting out
with the Little Golden Books
and she had a copy of
the Little Golden Book
because her mother would let
her brother and her take turns
about choosing the Little
Golden Book and she said,
but I wasn't very generous
because I see I've scratched
out my brother's name
and written mine,
but she had gotten the whole
town involved in this celebration
of books and so the parents
came, the city fathers came,
school superintendent came,
everybody came to the school
and did all kinds of book
related things all day.
It was just a glorious experience
and I thought these are the
teachers we have out there
and we should honor them and
pay them properly for one thing.
>> John Cole: I should
explain to the audience,
that during the two year
period with the consent
of the individual Ambassadors,
we try to spread them
across the country and
with these three plus
with Walter Dean Myers we hit
some of the spots in the country
that normally have travelling
authors, don't benefit from it.
When we started the program,
the idea was for certain,
the Ambassador would
come to The Library
of Congress National Book Festival,
which they all have and for certain,
they would go to New York for
the Children's Book Council
to be involved in the launch
of children's book week,
which by the way we are
also part of right now
and we are also considering
this The Library
of Congress launch of
children's book week.
And I do recall, in particular,
we sent you to some
very interesting places.
Anyone want to volunteer a place
that they will never forget
and they would like to go back to?
Or you can take it just
the first half hour.
>> Jon Scieszka: That's
a lot of questions.
>> John Cole: I know too much.
Let's say unforgettable place.
>> Katherine Paterson:
Well, I just said Maine.
>> Jon Scieszka: I'll say Maine.
You already said that.
Kate, you say something.
>> Kate DiCamillo: I'm going
to go to Alaska in June
and I've never been so I'm
looking forward to that
and we had an amazing time in
South Dakota that was just...
>> John Cole: Isn't
that quite a book fair?
>> Kate DiCamillo: That
was absolutely incredible.
>> John Cole: It's the South
Dakota Center for the Book which is
in the Humanities Council
has a knockout book festival
and did you go to which city?
>> Kate DiCamillo: I
was in Sioux Falls.
>> John Cole: Sioux Falls.
>> Kate DiCamillo: And
I live in Minnesota,
so South Dakota's not that far away.
I had never been and that's the
thing about the Ambassador program.
It's not where you're normally
like going and it was amazing.
Absolutely amazing.
>> John Cole: And Chris I remember
your dad went to South Dakota
as well and it turned out
to be such a popular spot
that we moved them each, two
of the Ambassadors through.
The Children's Book Council
does kind of the bookying,
if the Ambassador is willing to go
much beyond, and you all have been
for which we're very grateful, but
you know it's an individual choice
on how much traveling you
can do and want to do.
>> Jon Scieszka: Well,
I was even most amazed
by a place even closer to home.
Went to a place in Manhattan
that was a subway ride away
on the lower east side where 75
percent of the kids were homeless,
but they were all writing books.
I got to see the books they wrote
and I actually didn't
even read any of my books.
We read all of their books
and it was a great moment
of like oh this is a visit.
This is a visit.
>> John Cole: Jon, I remember
you're being the first Ambassador,
we were fussing about how to promote
it and we had at the ALA mid-winter,
we actually had a big raffle
and people could put their name
of their school and why they wanted
to get a visit from the Ambassador.
Now we got off of that
after the first time.
>> Jon Scieszka: That
was just awkward, yes.
I paved the way for you guys.
I went to birthday parties.
I think a couple Bar Mitzvahs.
John had me in a parking lot.
I opened a bridge, a Costco.
They named a school after me,
but no one could spell it.
>> John Cole: But we had a special
time with Katherine in Vermont
because you remember Guy and I
both came up for a special talk
that you gave and to having
her Vermont connections,
I gave the people of Vermont
a chance to really participate
in a home state that we quite
haven't had the chance to do
with the rest of you it's
true, this program progresses
and of course the Ambassadors
are chosen by our jury each year
where we're going to become even
more National than we've been.
>> Jon Scieszka: Well, I love
the opportunities we go just
with the title.
Like to be in the New
York Times Newspaper.
>> Kate DiCamillo: Right.
>> Jon Scieszka: I went on Martha
Stewart for no apparent reason other
than being the Ambassador.
>> Kate DiCamillo: What did they
tell you the apparent reason was?
>> Jon Scieszka: I don't know.
I came out of the audience
and I made cookies together,
kind of, for a little bit.
And then she asked me my
tips on how kids could read
or she gave me her tips actually.
It was kind of a Martha
Stewart thing.
Who thought closed captioning
on t.v. would be good?
>> John Cole: Where was she
when she gave you those tips?
>> Jon Scieszka: Prison actually.
>> John Cole: I set you up for that.
>> Jon Scieszka: That's the
only thing I could think of.
>> John Cole: Katherine's
going to speak.
>> Jon Scieszka: Yeah,
let Katherine talk.
>> Kate DiCamillo: It's
better if Katherine talks.
>> Katherine Paterson:
See how old I am.
The oldest National
Ambassador anyhow.
>> Jon Scieszka: The
oldest stateswoman.
>> Katherine Paterson:
The elder stateswoman.
>> Jon Scieszka: The
more mature one.
>> Katherine Paterson: But
the great thing about it was
when I first started
in this business,
the reporters who had drawn the
short straw and would have to come
and interview me would always have
to explain before they
began the interview
that they usually interviewed
important people.
>> Jon Scieszka: They're
bringing it down a notch for you.
>> Katherine Paterson: Yeah.
Yeah and they got the short
straw so they had to do me
and what's the difference between
a children's book and a book
for adults and do you
do all the pictures
and you know that sort of thing.
And this time because I'm so old,
the reporters had read my books
when they were children and the
interviews were just wonderful
because we had a great time talking
about things we all knew about.
And I just thought that was the
big bonus of being an elderly,
a very elderly National Ambassador.
>> John Cole: You can
say, having been around.
>> Katherine Paterson: Having
been around for a long time.
>> Jon Scieszka: Well, Kate did
you get on some weird things
like radio and television?
>> Kate DiCamillo: I didn't
go on the Martha Stewart show.
I mean she's not called me.
What weird things?
>> Jon Scieszka: I don't know.
>> Kate DiCamillo:
What have your heard?
>> Jon Scieszka: I heard
a lot of you on the radio?
And Desperate Housewives
I thought I saw you.
Is that not true?
>> Kate DiCamillo: That is not true.
I mean I've done all kinds of things
that I would not normally
have come my way, I think
and Katherine I'm not
an elder stateswoman,
but I've been doing this long
enough now that adults appear before
who say I read your book when
I was growing up and it's one
of the most profound
things in the world.
It is. I don't know of anybody
who has read "The True Story
of the Three Little Pigs" when they
were a kid and now is an adult.
Do we have somebody like that?
>> Jon Scieszka: Yeah, yeah.
That's 25 years ago.
>> Kate DiCamillo: Wow!
It's probably not as profound and
moving for him as it is for me.
>> Jon Scieszka: It's
a little profound.
Not much.
>> John Cole.
How about the most fun moment?
Can a fun moment be separated from
some of these more serious moments?
>> Jon Scieszka: Oh yeah.
My favorite one was I was
traveling with Dave Shannon
who was a very goofy
guy wrote "No David".
Where that's the whole book.
So, David and I came to a school is
California and just before we walk
in the auditorium, the teacher said,
they've composed an
Ambassador fanfare for you.
So, the kids had made a whole
dandanadantada and Dave and I walked
into this thing and I got to
make Dave my vice Ambassador
so he walked in front of me...
>> John Cole: What?
What?
>> Jon Scieszka: It's
in the fine print.
I made him carry my bag in...
>> Katherine Paterson:
And charge a vice.
>> Jon Scieszka: And just walked
in and we did it like three times
because it was so much fun.
And then on the way out, that's
when Dave explained to kids
that you just don't say hello
and goodbye to an Ambassador.
You have salom.
I know you didn't follow
up much with that.
You just made the kids go ohhh.
>> Katherine Paterson: I
guess I missed out on a lot
by not asking for adulation.
>> Jon Scieszka: Yeah, you just ask.
What could go wrong?
>> John Cole: Well, Katherine, the
best moments I remember with you was
in Louisiana when we were both
at the Louisiana Book Festival
and your husband John
was there and your talk,
if you recall was actually in
the State Capitol building.
>> Katherine Paterson: Huey
Long's State Capitol wasn't it?
>> John Cole: Hmm?
>> Katherine Paterson:
Huey Long's State Capital.
>> John Cole: Huey Long,
where Huey Long was shot.
>> Jon Scieszka: Yeah.
>> John Cole: So, yeah it was...
>> Katherine Paterson: Yeah that
was so fun and those people were
so great, they invited
me back for next year.
>> John Cole: I know, well they
really take their book festivals
very seriously and they have
a wonderful book festival.
>> Katherine Paterson: Mmmhmm.
It was.
>> John Cole: Jon, do
they have a fanfare?
Just asking.
So, Kate how about for you?
>> Kate DiCamillo: Probably the most
fun has been explaining to people
that I'm the Ambassador and that
Jon was the first Ambassador
and then making fun of Jon
for five or six minutes
without him being anywhere
in the state.
[ Inaudible ]
And then after I'm finished with
Jon, then I move on to Katherine
and Walter and sing their praises,
but I don't sing your praises.
>> Jon Scieszka: Oh, I know.
There's this thing called Twitter.
>> John Cole: Good, well
we're going to wrap this up.
Well, you reminded me that we
still have a way of hearing
about Walter's Ambassadorship and
we're going to have a film clip
in a second and we also will have
a conversation including Chris,
at which time we can talk
a little bit about Walter
and some of his contributions.
One of them and I will say
just a word about was just
about the time Walter
became Ambassador,
he knew knew what his theme was
going to be and we will hear
about it in the film clip,
but the idea of the them is
something the Ambassador can use
or not use, depending on
whether they're interested in it
and the tours that are planned.
Another interesting thing
that happens is that all
of our Ambassadors have
distinguished publishers
and during their Ambassadorship,
each of them will have books
or have books that are being
worked on and so we've worked
on a relationship with the
publishers who've been very
supportive of this whole idea
and it's one of the ways I think
that we're going to going to be able
to reach even more people and more
through future Ambassadorships.
>> Jon Scieszka: Well,
it's been nice
to have multiple Ambassadors
now too.
Because we were kind of making
it up as we went along Katherine
and now we have a whole
gang or gaggle?
>> Katherine Paterson:
Yeah, I felt like one
of the things I got the most
credit for as Ambassador.
In fact, I tend to take
credit for is that I was
on the committee that chose Walter.
>> Jon Scieszka: Ahh.
Good move.
>> John Cole: Yeah, and that's one
of the mechanics we've worked out is
that the previous Ambassador
and of course, Jon,
you should just came
out of the cold.
>> Jon Scieszka: Could
you rephrase that?
>> John Cole: You had
no previous Ambassador
to nominate or endorse you.
>> Jon Scieszka: That
was another positive.
>> John Cole: So, we had to
do a lot of careful research
and it was quite a debate.
But we won.
>> Jon Scieszka: I kind
of love that I did get
to make it up as I went along.
It was just like I don't know maybe
the Ambassador does get to do that.
>> Katherine Paterson:
I think everybody understands it'll
be a little hard to follow Jon.
>> Kate DiCamillo: Yes.
>> John Cole: Great.
Well, I am going to move now to
the tribute which we are going
to have about Walter Dean Myers.
We are honored that Christopher
Myers, as you already know,
has joined us to pay tribute to
his father, Walter Dean Myers.
Walter was our third Ambassador
and served between 2012 and 2013
if you can keep track
of all of this.
But before Chris comes to
the podium, we want to share
with you a brief video clip from
a July 2012 interview with Walter
by Jeffrey Brown of the PBS News
Hour and I think those of us
on the stage will just...
>> Katherine Paterson:
We can look right there.
>> John Cole: Oh, there it is.
Alright, let's go.
>> Finally tonight.
One man's need to write
and society's need to read.
Jeffrey Brown talks with author
and advocate, Walter Dean Myers.
>> Walter Dean Myers: I was raised
[ inaudible ]
and I was raised in Harlem.
>> Jeffrey Brown: And on
this day, it was to Harlem
that author Walter
Dean Myers returned.
At 74, Myers is the Library of
Congress National Ambassador
for Young People's literature.
The first African American
to hold the post.
He'd come to his old neighborhood
to talk to with second graders
at St. Aloysius School
about his life
as a writer and his need to read.
Something Myers' own
father never learned to do.
>> How did you feel that you didn't
know your father couldn't read?
Did you feel sad?
>> Walter Dean Myers: Actually a
funny thing because he had died
and then I discovered
he couldn't read,
but what happened during his
lifetime, he never praised my books.
He never said anything good about my
books and so, I felt bad about that.
I thought he didn't like them and
I was too embarrassed to ask him.
When I found out he couldn't
read I really felt bad
because I could have
taught him how to read.
>> Jeffrey Brown: So, what do you
get by coming to a school like this?
>> Walter Dean Myers: Well, it
reminds me of why I'm writing.
>> Jeffrey Brown: Why
you're writing?
>> Walter Dean Myers:
Why you're writing?
It validates what I'm
doing and I realize
that I'm giving the kids something
and what I'm doing is telling them
that their lives are worthwhile.
>> Jeffrey Brown: Myers is author
of more than 100 novels, biographies
and other books for young
adults and children.
Some of the latter illustrated
by his son Christopher.
All together his works have
sold more than a million copies
and frequently focus on the
gritty side of city life.
One that he's lived and knows still
from visits to detention centers
and prisons as well as
school around the country.
The best selling novel,
"Monster" for example is
about a Harlem teen jailed
as an accomplice in a murder.
"Hoops" features a young basketball
player whose coach gambles
on their championship game.
A new book, "Just Write, Here's
How" tells of Myers' own troubles in
and out of school, how
reading and writing saved him
and how they can help others too.
You've taken this new
role as Ambassador
of Young People's Literature, but
I read about your life and it seems
as though that's a role that you
assigned yourself a long time ago.
>> Walter Dean Myers: Yeah,
I've always been interested
in young people reading
and you know,
when I go to the juvenile
detention centers and prisons,
I see people who can't
read and I know
that when they leave those
prisons and detention centers,
they're not going to be
able to make it in society.
I'm also old enough to know
that reading has changed.
>> Jeffrey Brown: Changed
in what way?
>> Walter Dean Myers: Well, it's
changed in that when I was young,
there were many, many
people who could go out
and get a job in a factory.
Or they could get a
job doing some sort
of physical work and
make a good living.
Or at least a good
enough living to make it.
Now, you can't do that.
Even the job that you think is
pretty good today may not be
around in five years, so
you have to be able to read.
It's not like it's a nice thing to
do or funny adjunct, it's essential.
>> Jeffrey Brown: Growing up, Myers
says that he always loved reading,
but found few examples of
kids like him in books.
His own path took many turns.
He dropped out of high
school, joined the army
and worked a variety of jobs.
Eventually, he started
writing in off hours.
When you were growing up
and you write about this,
the idea of being a writer, that
one could make a living and sort
of be writer was unheard
of in your background.
>> Walter Dean Myers:
It was completely unheard
of, but I liked to write.
I couldn't speak well.
I was in speech therapy for ten
years and I was so frustrated
in that sense, but I
found that I love reading
and I liked writing stories.
I never thought of
making a living at it.
I never thought about
making a living at writing.
I didn't even know for years that
people ever even got paid for this.
They don't teach you that in school.
They don't say Shakespeare
got a check, you know.
Or Shelley was getting royalties.
They don't tell you that.
They make it sound like
these guys were geniuses
and they were above money.
>> Jeffrey Brown: The
speech impediment,
also something you write about,
being laughed at as a child.
>> Walter Dean Myers:
Luckily I was big.
>> Jeffrey Brown: That meant
what getting into fights?
>> Walter Dean Myers: I
got into many, many fights.
and many I would start.
I would start the fights
because someone would smile,
and they could be smiling
at anything,
but I thought people were laughing
at me so I would be very aggressive.
>> Jeffrey Brown: The
young adult novels
that perhaps you're best
known for now are tough stuff.
I mean you're looking at
some real tough issues
in the lives of young people right?
>> Walter Dean Myers: They're
tough issues, they're tough issues.
I started writing sports,
I was writing adventure,
I was writing mysteries, but
then I began going to prisons.
I began to realize that
these guys had families
or who's raising your kids?
Then I began going to
juvenile prisons and some
of these kids face some
very, very tough lives
and how do they handle these lives?
Do they even know that if their
life is bad that they're still ok.
Do they know that?
Do they know that someone
is thinking the same way
that they're thinking.
>> Jeffrey Brown: Of course
a lot of people, I suppose,
would think that is this stuff
for young people to read?
You know, to read about
prison and drugs and poverty.
Why not give them something
more positive?
>> Walter Dean Myers: The most
positive I can give them is their
own presence acknowledging them.
You know if I say to a kid, you are
a human being that I understand.
You know, I'm not going to excuse
you if you've done a crime.
I'm not going to excuse your crime,
but I know where you're coming from.
I know that you feel and that you're
thinking and I need to do that.
I need to write that.
>> Jeffrey Brown: And
keep writing he will.
This spring, Myers
published his latest novel,
"All the Right Stuff"
set again in Harlem.
It tells the story
of a young man trying
to find direction in his life.
In the meantime, Myers will
continue to proselytize
in his role as a reading Ambassador.
His mantra he says,
reading is not optional.
[ Clapping ]
>> John Cole: Christopher Myers
is an author and illustrator
who won a Caldecott Honor for his
illustrations in "Harlem: A Poem",
a book by his father, Walter Dean
Myers and a Coretta Scott King Honor
for "H.O.R.S.E" for "Jazz" and "The
Black Cat" which he also wrote.
In 2015, he won the Coretta
King Award for illustration
for "Firebird" by the ballet
dancer Misty Copeland.
He began his career by doing
research to help his father
and then went on to illustrate
many of his father's books.
A brief summary of Walter's
career includes over 80 books
for children and young adults.
Walter received two Newbery Honors,
five Coretta Scott King Awards
and the Inaugural Virginia Hamilton
Award for Lifetime Achievement.
He won the first Michael
L. Prince Award
and in 1994 received the American
Library Association's Margaret A.
Edwards Award for Significant
and Lasting Contribution
to Young Adult Literature.
Join me in welcoming
Christopher Myers to the podium.
[ Clapping ]
>> Christopher Myers: Dad was so
excited when he got his medal.
He was a little bit like you Jon.
He carried it around.
He wore it through the streets
of Harlem and he loved the idea
that people would look
at him and say,
what's that guy got a medal on for?
You know, he loved that.
He took it very seriously.
He took it very, very seriously
and I think that in this idea
of being the National Ambassador
for Young People's Literature,
we've talked a lot about young
people, we've talked a lot
about literature and the awkwardness
of Ambassador or whatever
that means, but that national thing.
That thing to be invited to
here, The Library of Congress,
really stuck with Dad in
a certain kind of way.
As you can see, he thought of
himself as like a young guy
from Harlem that's all of a
sudden the nation had recognized
in a certain way and he thought
that was super important.
And I thought maybe just in terms
of thinking what it meant to him
to be the National Ambassador,
I wanted to focus on that bit.
That nation thing.
This country is unique in
the world and everybody says
that about their country.
I don't care if you're from Zimbabwe
or from Miranmar or whatever,
everyone says my country's unique.
But there is something really
unique about this country
that it's founded on words.
All the other countries
are founded on history,
we've been living here quite some
time, etc. This country is founded
in documents, in words, in
declarations, in constitutions,
in inalienable rights, in I
have not yet begun to fights
and this country continues
to be sustained by words.
This is a place of speeches, of
four score and seven years ago,
of fear of self, of
I have a dream, of
[ foreign language ]
. Of all of these words, this
is what makes this country,
is that we are a country of words
and so when we are challenged,
when we have problems, we continue
to turn toward language, right.
So, we go to I am woman,
hear my roar,
we go to by any means necessary,
we go to black lives matter.
This is how our country functions.
We think in terms of language
and so when I look at these guys
and I think about what
my father did,
I realize that these guys are the
guys that write the passports.
They write the passports for all
of you young people to fully enter
into this countryness because
they invite people into language.
They invite young people
into language
and to take full part in language.
When Pop would go to schools, when
I would go to schools with Dad,
you know there are a lot of schools.
I've been doing this
for a short time.
He did this forever.
Some of these folks have been
doing it for a minute as well.
You realize that when you go to the
school that these kids are looking
at you and they're
looking to be invited.
Schools are even not as poignant or
as real as when you go to prisons,
when you go to juvenile prisons,
here are kids that have been told
that they are not part of
this, that or the other thing.
They are not able to
wear proper shoes,
because they can't control
the clothing they wear.
They're wearing flip flops often
because that's what it means
to be in juvenile detention.
And what Dad did is he invited those
kids to take part in the country
of language that he was
so much a member of.
The thing that got him out of what
could have been a dead end life
as a high school dropout, etc,,
etc. Language was his passport,
language is our passport and so when
we're in this repository of language
that makes a nation, it's
really exciting to realize
that it starts really young.
It starts with the language that
invites us to be in Terabithia,
or dealing with the stinky
cheese man, or Winn Dixie.
I'm talking about the
books that I read,
but like that is what the
National Ambassadorship means.
It's this invitation to language
and it's and understanding
that language is at the center
of what it means to be part
of this country in so many ways.
So, then about a year ago Dad and I
wrote these articles for the Times,
hold on, I got some
notes, just making sure.
Dad and I wrote some articles
for the Times about diversity
in young people's literature
and what we found
and what we were worried about was
how many kids we'd seen throughout
the country who were not in their
way being invited into language.
Not being invited into the
world that had given us so much.
I was raised on books,
and when I say raised
on books, I was fed on books.
That was, you know every
piece of stitch of clothing
that I had was made through the
hard work of my dad's long fingers
at a keyboard and books have given
me so much and so we realized
that there were all these kids
in the world and the country
who had not been invited into
that nation and so we think
that that is one of the things that
we want to change in this world.
That we're really lucky to have
had a platform through Pops thing
about reading is not optional.
Like reading is not something that
you want to leave anybody out of
and we're also really lucky that
the Library of Congress has worked
with a movement that started
after our articles called
"We need diverse books" and
they've decided that they're going
to have a reward for books
that think about diversity,
that bring diversity to the
fore, that invite more people
into language and they're
calling it "The Walter".
[ Clapping ]
>> Which through the center for the
book, the young reader's center,
the point is that next year
March we're going to be giving
out this award and Dad would have
been tickled as he was tickled
to be a part of you guys.
As he was tickled to not be
only invited into the language
of the country, of the language
of books and to the language
of the nationhood, but to
be lauded, to get a medal
that said he was a member and
to sit with you guys and to say,
man I'm a National
Ambassador like them.
So, I just wanted to thank you
for that experience in his life
because there's a way
in which, I think,
for everybody that makes
kid's books, there's an age
that you've stopped in your head
and that you're always that kid.
My dad, he was maybe ten.
He was in Harlem, it
wasn't an easy life.
He was afraid of things, he
was nervous about things,
he didn't know what his future
had ahead of him and so for him
to be able to turn to that
ten year old kid inside him
and say oh, it's going to be good.
You're going to be a
National Ambassador.
First of all, that ten year
old kid didn't believe him,
but he got to prove that
ten year old kid wrong.
So, thank you.
[ Clapping ]
>> John Cole: Thank
you so much Chris.
That was wonderful and just
evoked that fourth ambassadorship
in ways that our hard to count.
It was terrific.
And stay tuned because the
first "Walter" will be presented
at the Library of Congress
next March.
>> Jon Scieszka: Sounds good.
>> Katherine Paterson:
That's wonderful.
>> John Cole: I don't mean
that as a casual comment,
it's just that this
is a project underway
and it involves many partners and
many groups and many organizations
and we're thrilled that it will
be presented here at the Library
and we can continue to do this
kind of very meaningful work.
I wanted to thank all of our
distinguished Ambassadors,
Jon Scieszka, Katherine
Paterson and Kate DiCamillo.
Give them a round of applause.
[ Clapping ]
>> John Cole: And our special
guest, Christopher Myers.
[ Clapping ]
>> John Cole: I want to
thank our Center for the book
and our Young Reader Center's Staff,
especially it's head, Karen Jaffee.
Karen, where are you?
There you are.
Thank you Karen.
Plus, the volunteers that have
helped us put this wonderful
event together.
A round of applause for them.
[ Clapping ]
>> John Cole: And also I
have a special announcement
for the students in the audience.
Today, also in addition to be being
our celebration of the Ambassador
and the Library of Congress marking
the children's book week is a
kickoff of a special Library
of Congress special program,
"A book that shaped me"
summer reading contest.
Now in its fourth year for
students entering fifth
or sixth grades this fall.
We ask that such students write
a one page essay on a book
about a book that has made
a difference in your life.
This contest is administered
through local library's summer
reading programs in Washington,
Maryland, Virginia, Delaware,
Pennsylvania and West Virginia
where you students can submit
your own essays this summer.
Winners receive up to
300 dollars in prizes
and present their essay the Library
of Congress National Book Festival
over Labor Day weekend
on September the fifth
at the Walter E.Washington
Convention Center and you can pick
up your entry form as you
leave today's presentation.
Finally, the Children's Book Council
has provided a Children's Book Week
poster for each of the students.
Now, we are going to
have a brief question
and answer period before we close.
We have a few minutes and I would
like to ask for the first question
from the audience and I'm
going to be straining.
Over here, thank you.
All the way over.
>> I would just like to ask all four
of you if there's anything that out
of all the books that you've wrote,
is there like a special lesson
that you would like everyone that
reads all your books to take?
>> Kate DiCamillo: Wow,
that's a tough one.
Do you want Jon to start with that?
>> Jon Scieszka: Yes, I think
the lesson I want everyone
to learn is don't make a little
man out of bad smelling cheese.
Not a good idea.
>> Katherine Paterson: Well,
I always feel like that
the writer has no right
to tell what the lesson is.
That all of us when we read a book,
we get to take whatever
we want to learn from it.
Now, the teacher might tell you
there's a certain lesson in the book
and for the test you can say
that, but really in your heart,
you get to decide what the
lesson of the book is for you
and if there's no lesson, fine.
>> Kate DiCamillo: And
I think that's true too
and also what I have found
and probably you have
found this Katherine,
and you have found this Christopher,
you have not found this,
that writing the book
teaches you something,
as the writer that you
didn't realize going into it.
Maybe even Jon has learned that too.
>> Katherine Paterson: No, I
think that's true because a lot
of times you write a book because
you have a question that you want
to answer and you don't
have the answer
until after you've written the
book, but that's your answer.
It might not be the
reader's answer at all.
>> Kate DiCamillo: That's true.
>> John Cole: Another
question from our audience?
All the way in the
back please, thank you.
>> So, I have a question for Kate.
What inspired you to write
the Mercy Watson series?
>> Kate DiCamillo: Well, actually
it's a good question to lead
from this question because
when you write books for kids,
what adults always say to you
is what lesson did you mean
to impart here.
And the Mercy Watson books are
the answer to that question
because nobody ever learns
anything in those books.
You know, the pig goes right on
being a pig and I had the idea
for the story of a pig who lived
with two people who were not pigs
and I thought it was really
funny and I kept on playing
around with it, but I couldn't
make it work until I got a new car
and I was taking a friend to
the airport the very first day
that I had this new car and she got
into the car with a gigantic piece
of toast that had a ton of butter
on it and she started to eat it
in my brand new car spraying greasy
crumbs everywhere and I said stop
that and instead of her stopping
eating the toast, she talked to me
about the virtues of toast and
how it should be well buttered
and how it tasted better
if somebody made it for you
and by the time I got rid of her,
I knew what was missing in the book
about the pig, which is what
the pig loved which is toast
and that's the deep
meaning of those books.
Right.
>> Jon Scieszka: Wow, that's a lot.
>> I have a question for all of you.
Do you have a special place
where you like to think
about what your books
are going to be?
>> Kate DiCamillo: Oh,
that's a very good question.
I want to go first.
>> Jon Scieszka: No, I want to.
No, you go.
>> Kate DiCamillo: Alright.
I always have a notebook that
I carry with me and I have
that all the time and I write ideas
down in that, but to write I have
to be at my desk facing
a blank wall.
So, that's where the
writing actually gets done.
>> Jon Scieszka: That's weird.
>> Kate DiCamillo: You can
write anywhere can't you?
>> Jon Scieszka: Yeah, I
don't have any special place.
I have any place.
I'm writing right now.
It doesn't look like it, but I am.
That's what I tell my editor.
>> John Cole: Katherine?
You want to respond to that?
>> Katherine Paterson:
Well, I'm always embarrassed
when a real writer like Kate talks
about carrying her notebook around
and writing down ideas because
all for when I go to school,
people say don't you keep a
notebook with ideas and I say no
and they say, don't you
keep a journal and I say no.
>> Jon Scieszka: Don't
let our all your secrets.
>> Katherine Paterson: Well, by
the time we're through I say,
let's face it, whatever
real writers do, I don't.
So, yeah I have a place to write and
right now it's covered with stuff
that has nothing to do with what I'm
trying to write so I think I've got
to go home and clean
up and get to work.
>> John Cole: Christopher,
do you want to respond
about your working habits?
>> Christopher Myers: Well, in
terms of places, I travel a lot
and that often informs what I'm
working on, so I was just in Italy
where I got a grant to
have a studio there.
It was very inspirational.
Italian food, I have found
is quite inspirational.
>> Jon Scieszka: Why are all
your books about spaghetti?
>> Christopher Myers: Although
Vietnamese food is very
inspirational, I was
there for a while.
Food in Brooklyn.
Food, food that's also a
part of my creative process.
>> Katherine Paterson: But I
think Christopher should talk
about his new book because I think
that's great for kids to know about.
>> Christopher Myers:
I just finished a book,
a book called "My Pen".
And it's about that I do carry
a notebook and a pen with me.
Where's yours?
It's not on stage with you?
>> Kate DiCamillo: It's in my purse
>> Christopher Myers: It's far away.
If you had an idea now, I would
take it from you and write it down.
>> Jon Scieszka: I'm
writing it down up here.
>> Christopher Myers: But
I'm interested in the idea
that you know all you really
need, I was in a prison with Pop
and the guy looked at me,
looked at Dad and goes,
you know when you guys don't
dress particularly well,
you don't have nice
watches or anything.
Do you live in a mansion?
And I was like I live in Brooklyn
in an apartment and they were
like what kind of power
do you have and I was
like I'm really, really
good with a pen.
And so as long as I have a pen,
no matter where I am,
I can do something.
You know, be it drawing
and I'm also beginning
to realize how much is
around us is all pens.
You know, from how the podiums
designed to you know your clothing.
You know, there's somebody with
a pen somewhere who drew that,
you know, so this idea of as
long as you have a pen no matter
where you are, you go something.
>> Katherine Paterson:
It's a great book.
>> John Cole: Right in
the front, thank you.
>> This is for all you guys.
How did it feel when you
wrote your first book?
>> John Cole: Could you repeat
the question once for us?
>> How did it feel when
you wrote your first book?
>> John Cole: How did you feel
when you wrote your first book?
>> Kate DiCamillo:
Who wants to go first?
>> John Cole: Round robin.
>> Jon Scieszka: Katherine, tell us.
>> Katherine Paterson:
Well, it's been so long.
I had written a book just because
I had been asked to write a book
by the church, but my first
novel, I had gone for seven years
and sold practically nothing and one
short story and the magazine folded,
but I decided if I could
write a story a week,
none of which were selling, I could
even write a chapter a week and even
if nobody ever bought
it or published it,
I would have accomplished
something by the end of the year.
So, I set myself the task
of writing a chapter a week.
I know that book only has 14
chapters and a year has 52 weeks,
but anyhow by the end of the year
I had a rough draft of the book
and it eventually sold and
it became my first novel
so when people say they don't have
time to write and when they get old
and don't have anything
else to do they'll write,
I think maybe you have
more time than you think,
but you just don't have the nerve
because I think writing
takes a lot of nerve.
Don't you guys?
>> Jon Scieszka: Yeah, because I
remember writing Three Little Pigs
writing in an office in New
York and nobody liked it.
Everyone thought it was too stupid.
Either that or they thought
kids wouldn't understand it
and I thought no, I
think they get it.
So, it took like a year of people
saying no, this is too weird
and then I met the illustrator.
He did some drawings and they
said, now it's really too weird.
Now, we're really not going to
publish it, so it's a sad memory.
Until it came out and sold a bunch.
>> Katherine Paterson:
A million books later.
>> Jon Scieszka: Yeah, yeah.
>> Kate DiCamillo: My first
book was "Because of Winn Dixie"
and I was working in
book warehouse and...
>> Jon Scieszka: And you
didn't even have shoes right?
>> Kate DiCamillo: I
didn't even have shoes.
I read your dad in that warehouse.
I was assigned all children's books.
I read Katherine Paterson
in that warehouse.
I walked passed Jon's books.
No, I got to study everybody
and then Winn Dixie was going
to join the ranks of these
people that I loved and knew
through their books and it was just
the most amazing thing in the world
and it still, it surprises
me every day.
I don't know if you all feel
that way because you grew
up with your dad doing it.
>> Christopher Myers:
Yeah, so for my first book,
I'd seen my dad publishing books
and I'd illustrated a book.
The first one I illustrated one
with him and he got half the money
because he did the words and
then I did the and then I said,
I can cut you out and so when
I published my first book,
I was excited because
I was like see,
I don't even need this
whole half the money.
I like all of it.
That's much better for me.
Such an uplifting question.
>> Katherine Paterson: This wasn't
a question, but I can remember
when I read Kate's first book
because somebody gave it to me
and they said you're
going to love this book
and I thought this woman is
kin to me, I want to meet her.
>> Kate DiCamillo: That still
makes me cry when you say that.
>> John Cole: Alright, we'll
go to this question over here.
>> Well, I have this
for Kate DiCamillo.
>> Kate DiCamillo: Yes.
>> What inspired you to
make "Flora and Ulysses"
because I am still confused
about how you thought
of a squirrel lifting up a 100
or 200 pound vacuum cleaner?
>> Kate DiCamillo: He's a superhero.
So, it is always very complicated
to trace these ideas back,
but I have those notebooks
that Katherine doesn't have
and Jon doesn't have and I could go
back and trace how it all happened
and so, my mom who passed away in
2009, she had a vacuum cleaner,
and Electrolux vacuum cleaner
and she thought it was the
most incredible vacuum cleaner
and in the last year of her
life, she talked to me a lot
about what was going to happen
to the vacuum cleaner
when she was gone.
And I kept saying, I'll take the
vacuum cleaner don't worry about it.
So, she passed away, I did
take the vacuum cleaner
because I promised her I would.
However, she had a cat.
The world's most evil cat named
Mildew and I'm allergic to cats.
Are you following this because
it is all going to come together.
So, I'm allergic to cats so I
couldn't put the vacuum cleaner
in the house because I needed
to detoxify it, so
it was in the garage.
Every time I would
pull in the garage,
I would see the vacuum
cleaner, it would make me sad,
it would make me miss my mother.
So, there's the vacuum cleaner.
So, the spring after she
died there's a squirrel dying
on my front steps.
Like draped across it in
a very dramatic fashion,
obviously not going to get well.
I called one of my best friends,
who lives a block and a half away.
She's asked me not to
say her name anymore.
She's really the sweetest and
gentlest of all of my friends,
but what she said when I told
her there was a squirrel dying
on my front steps was,
do you have a shovel?
I was like, yeah I have a shovel.
She said get the shovel and and
old t-shirt and I'll come over
and whack him over the head.
So, I'm on the cell phone with
her, very close to the squirrel
and I start backing up
because I don't want him
to hear what she just said, right.
I go around to the side door, go
in and look out the front door
and guess what, the squirrel is gone
because he did hear and he thought,
that is not the death for me.
I'm going to go someplace else
and die a more quiet
and dignified death.
So, I started to think about
ways to save a squirrel
and I've got this vacuum cleaner
and I these two things
together and there you go.
Now you understand.
>> John Cole: Alright,
we'll go to the back please.
>> Katherine Paterson:
I need a notebook.
>> How do you guys feel
when you win an award?
>> Kate DiCamillo: I want
to go first with that one
because I was a kid who
was lucky enough to go
to the library twice a week.
There was a spin rack in the library
that had all the Newbery,
Yearling paperbacks.
Raise your hand if you are
old enough to remember those.
They were all and I knew that
the Newbery Medal on a book meant
that it was going to be a
book that I loved and to think
that that would be on
something that I wrote,
is something that I
still cannot get over.
You know?
>> Jon Scieszka: It still
great to win awards.
When I hear about new awards like
the Walter, I want to win it.
Like it's never been around
before, but now I've got a new one.
I've got a lot things I want,
but let's not get into that.
How about you Katherine?
>> Katherine Paterson:
Well, I guess...
>> Jon Scieszka: You've
got a slew of them.
>> Katherine Paterson: The first
award I won was the National Book
Award for "The Master
Puppeteer" and...
>> Jon Scieszka: That's
a nice way to start.
Don't start small, right.
No state awards.
>> Katherine Paterson:
Well, it was kind of weird
because in those days they
warned a few days ahead.
Now, you have to go to the thing
and they call out your name
like the Academy Awards which
is just horrible, but anyhow,
they called to say I was
nominated, but don't worry.
That's just a great
honor to be nominated.
Don't worry about winning the award,
but you will have to make a speech
so you should write a speech.
And I said, how am I going to
write a speech for an award
that I am not going to win.
>> Jon Scieszka: Oh, I
have those all ready.
>> Katherine Paterson: But then
they called and said I won,
but I had just heard my daughter
had been in a bike accident,
so I wasn't really worried about
writing a speech that had to be done
by five o'clock in the afternoon.
I was worried about
finding my daughter
and making sure she was alright.
So, I jump in the car to go to
where she is and she's fine.
Her bike is not ridable, so I
get all the kids home and I say,
if you'll give me quiet, I've
got to write 500 deathless words
and they gave me quiet and I wrote
500 deathless words and my husband,
of course, was out of town.
He was always out of town when
a crisis occurs and I took them
to this restaurant and
the next thing I knew all
of the wait staff had gathered
around the table singing
"For she's a jolly good fellow"
and they said, congratulations
to Katherine Paterson, the greatest
children's writer in the world
and my kids were beaming
and I was bright red,
but anyhow it was a great occasion.
>> Christopher Myers: In general,
it's good to win awards, I think.
>> Jon Scieszka: I think
that's a good summary.
It's nice.
>> Katherine Paterson:
It feels good.
>> John Cole: I should mention
that in Katherine's part I had
just finished her new book,
"The Stories of My Life" and she
talks about each of the awards
and the story behind them and the
way you just did for that first one
and it's really a wonderful story.
A footnote for you about awards.
We're going to move
up to this one please.
>> I have a question for all of you.
What was your favorite
book when you was a kid?
>> John Cole: Favorite
book when you were a kid?
>> Christopher Myers: Favorite book.
I had a lot of favorite books.
I read anything that had
myths and legends in it.
I read not nearly enough
of my father's work
because it was always
around and he was there.
Of those of us who live
with somebody who's working,
you don't really care about their
job, you're like that's nice
that you're working, that's cool.
I would like to read something,
comic books were big with me,
but at the same time I
read what was the book
that had Japanese dolls
on the cover?
>> Katherine Paterson:
That was "Master Puppeteer"
>> Christopher Myers: "Master
Puppeteer" and my father brought
that home for me and I liked that
and he was mad at me
that I liked that.
He wasn't mad at me
because I liked that,
but he was like why
haven't you read my books?
But, this one has Japanese dolls
on the cover, it's cool man.
You do a book with Japanese
dolls on the cover and I got you.
>> Jon Scieszka: Revenge reading.
I loved "Because of Winn
Dixie" when I was little.
No, my favorite book was
the "The Carrot Seed".
Have you ever read that?
>> Katherine Paterson: Yep.
>> Jon Scieszka: And the
more I thought about it,
the more I realized where my
whole life's attitude was formed.
Like this little guy
finds a carrot seed
and everyone tells him it's not
going to grow up, don't bother,
but he plants it and they still
say don't bother it's not going
to grow up, but he takes good care
of it and they say don't bother.
And the last page is he's got a
huge carrot in the wheelbarrow
and that's the whole book.
Good story.
>> Kate DiCamillo: For me,
I loved to read everything
until I got to "Black Beauty".
How many of you all have
read "Black Beauty"?
That book upset me so much, that I
like didn't want to read any book
that had an animal on
the cover after that.
So, I did not read "Charlotte's
Web" until I was 30 years old.
Every week I would look at Wilbur...
>> Jon Scieszka: You
skipped all animal books?
>> Kate DiCamillo: Mmmhmm.
>> Jon Scieszka: That's
a lot of them.
>> Kate DiCamillo:
Right, it sure is.
>> Christopher Myers: Because they
all have pretty much the same plot.
Right, the animal on the cover.
I don't feel good for
that animal later.
>> Kate DiCamillo: And
Wilbur looked so worried
on the cover of "Charlotte's Web".
It's like something terrible
is going to happen to this pig.
I don't want anything
to do with it so.
>> Jon Scieszka: I'm
thinking back now.
Yeah, "Old Yeller".
>> Christopher Myers:
Yeah, you know.
>> Kate DiCamillo: "Old Yeller".
"Where the Red Fern Grows".
>> Jon Scieszka: Yeah.
>> Christopher Myers: Yeah, put
an animal on the cover, mmhmm.
That animal's not lasting long.
>> Kate DiCamillo: And the irony
is I as a child would not read any
of the books my adult self has
written because I've got an animal
on the cover of everything
I've done.
So, that's some kind of weird...
>> Jon Scieszka: You're
very conflicted.
>> Kate DiCamillo: Not
about you, I'm not.
>> Jon Scieszka: Read
"The Carrot Seed".
>> John Cole: Alright,
let's go to this question.
>> I have a question for Jon.
On the cover of the book it
says mostly true stories.
How many stories are
true and what are they?
>> Jon Scieszka: Wow.
>> Kate DiCamillo: I
want to answer for him.
You've been listening to him.
How many of those stories
do you think are true?
Goose eggs.
>> Jon Scieszka: No,
no, that's not true.
Most of them are because we have
six boys and a cat and a dog
and a goldfish and
like little brothers
that threw up on each other.
And we accidentally did pee on Greg.
It wasn't our fault and
on the electric heater.
Those are all real, but
don't try that either.
I would say 98 percent.
>> Katherine Paterson: Are true.
>> Jon Scieszka: Are true.
I'm sticking with 98.
>> Kate DiCamillo: I'm
sticking with zero.
>> John Cole: Alright, we're
going to go back over here.
Thank you.
>> So, this is for all of you.
What book have you written
that most relates to your life?
>> John Cole: I'm sorry, will
you repeat the question once?
>> Oh ok. What book have you written
that most relates to your life?
>> John Cole: Most
relates to your life?
>> If you have one.
>> Katherine Paterson: Well,
I guess the book that I wrote
out of something that happened in
my family was "Bridge to Terabithia"
because my son's best friend has
been killed by lightning and I had
to somehow makes sense out of
something that didn't make sense.
The book that's most like
me probably is "Come Sing,
Jimmy Jo" because I'm
a shy show off.
>> Jon Scieszka: Yeah.
Yeah.
>> Katherine Paterson:
People don't believe I'm shy
until they see me in a small group.
>> Jon Scieszka: Me too.
>> Katherine Paterson: But who can
be shy sitting next to Jon Scieszka?
>> Jon Scieszka: I think
in my life it's "The Story
of the Three Little Pigs"
because it's not honestly
my fault, like ever.
Whatever the accusation.
>> Kate DiCamillo: For me,
I don't know I think
it's what's coming next.
The novel that's coming out next
year, but I think that a lot.
The thing that I've just
finished is the thing
that most accurately sums me up,
but then the next thing comes along.
What about you Chris?
>> Christopher Myers: I would say
"The Pen Book" I feel is really
that is it until the next book
and then the next book will be it,
but right now I really
do see everything
as everyone up here is a pen.
I feel like everything is about
pens and I'm pen oriented.
Years ago I did a book
about Harlem and I was
like everyone is from Harlem.
We're not, but...
>> John Cole: Well, that was
the final question and answer
and I have a couple more
announcements before we say a final
thank you to our participants.
First of all, when you go out,
in addition to the contest
that I talked about a little
earlier, picking up the forms.
The Children's Book Council has
provided a children's book week
poster for each of our students
as you leave the auditorium
and if you'll remember that
is one of the many purposes
of this wonderful event
that we've enjoyed together.
This is a full week and I know
that the Children's Book
Council has gone national
with children's book week in a
number of new ways and are reaching
across the nation and have really
strengthened children's book week
in the few years that we
worked together on this.
Finally, when we leave, we need
to leave, for logistical reasons,
exit by school and I'm
going to announce the order
and it will be the order in
which I introduced everyone.
I will give you the word
when you are to get up
and for that school to leave.
We'll start with Hyde Addison,
then Brent, John Eaton,
Washington Latin and Alice Beale.
But finally I want to one
more time call for a round
of gratitude and applause
[ Clapping ]
>> John Cole: Thank you.
>> John Cole: I want to say
that when we began this
I said it was going
to be a very special program and
it turned out to be because each
of the ambassadors plus Christopher
have really shared themselves
with us in terms of their writing
and their ambitions and especially
about the importance about
the work that they do.
Not just for us, but also
in some ways for themselves.
I think it's rare that you
have such an articulate,
caring group of writers who
have such a broad perspective
on what the work that they're doing
and how important that work is
in this case for the
entire world of literature.
So, we're pleased you were here.
We just want to express the
gratitude for our writers.
For the true value of what they do.
That we appreciate it and we really
appreciate them taking the effort
to spend their time, not only
here, but as national ambassadors
for young people's
literature so final round
and then I'm going
to announce the...
This has been a presentation
from The Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov